jetzt sind zugeschaltet eicher und ihr
bruder verwiesen
und natürlich ist das eine so tolle
nachricht jetzt kurz vor weihnachten
erst mal alles sagte dafür dass das so
funktioniert hat
aber man fragt sich natürlich jeder bei
uns in der redaktion meinte ja ist doch
klar dass der bruder passt in diesem
fall ist das gar nicht so klar wie war
das hat sich die ganze familie trotzdem
von anfang an testen lassen oder jetzt
wirklich als letzte hoffnung weil das
kann ja nicht schaden wir müssen uns das
vorstellen
also das war so es hieß dann bruder
könnte in frage kommen aber die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist sehr gering
und wir haben dann gesagt na ja es gibt
eine hoffnung und alle anderen dieses
wird vielleicht gar nicht funktionieren
und wir haben uns einen die kleine
hoffnung geklammert und ganz plötzlich
hieß es foto horst mega mega glücklich
ruder passt was für ein gefühl ist das
wenn man seiner schwester jetzt das
leben damit retten kann also hallo
erstmal ja es ist natürlich total
unbeschreibliches gefühl also ich bin
immer noch total berührt von dem ganzen
thema vor allem weil es halt noch die
eigene schwester ist ist es für mich
halt noch mal doppelt so viel an
emotionen aber ich freue mich halt total
für sie also es ist immer noch wir sind
immer noch ernst alle vom thema ferien
bietet kann ich mir das vorstellen wie
läuft so ein eingriff also so eine
knochenmarkspende ab ist das ein
eingriff vor dem man respekt oder gar
bisschen angst haben muss was haben sie
angst vor dem eingriff also angst habe
ich momentan aktuell nicht ich lasse es
einfach auf mich zukommen weil es so das
so gemacht wird ist nicht nur zwei
alternativen entweder ja oder nein
von daher möchte ich auch gar nicht so
noch tiefgründiger mich mit dem thema
befassen ich sage einfach etwas muss
gemacht werden sagt mir und ich mache es
also wenn du hast also dazu bruder macht
aber als letztes mal uns auch erzählt
wie dringend du diese spenden jetzt
braucht es damit gehört im märz kann es
dann schon losgehen
ist das jetzt der erste schritt oder
bedeutet das für dich dass du ganz
sicher danach gesund bist und endlich
deine frische und einlädt
genießen kannst also sie sind am
überlegen die machen im januar einen
test und wenn alles gut läuft wollen
dies im dezember im märz durchführen
und wenn es dann im märz wirklich
funktioniert dann nicht komplett
erhalten aber es ist ein noch sehr sehr
sehr sehr sehr schöner weg vor mir weil
ich mehrere wochen im krankenhaus sein
und es wird ein harter kampf seine war
das schaffe ich auch noch da sind wir
uns ganz sicher wir drücken die daumen
und wünschen natürlich alles alles gute
euch beiden alles alles gute vielen dank
dass ihr heute abend noch einmal mit uns
darüber gesprochen habt danke schön
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
weil bild schau dich je das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren